tenemos una función lineal por pedazos
por aquí donde para distintos intervalos
de nuestra variable x está definida por
líneas distintas verdad aquí tenemos las
funciones que nos definen líneas ahora
bien dependiendo de qué intervalo
consideremos tendremos una línea
distinta así que primero pensemos en su
dominio para después ver qué pasa con su
rango ok entonces pensemos qué es lo que
va a ocurrir con el dominio de esta
función y recordemos que el dominio es
el conjunto de valores de entrada que en
este caso son las x verdad para los que
la función g está definida muy bien así
que eso lo podemos checar del lado
derecho en los intervalos que que nos
definen las líneas para la variable x
verdad por ejemplo x necesariamente
tiene que ser mayor que menos 6 verdad
después sigue creciendo al menos 3 salta
por ejemplo aquí a menos 3 y sigue hasta
4 después de 4 salta de esta otra parte
y
llegamos hasta el valor 6 quiere decir
que no está definida para ningún valor
más chico o igual que menos 6 verdad y
eso nos lo da esta parte de aquí arriba
nuevamente no tenemos ningún agujero
desde menos 6 hasta menos 3 después
saltamos a esta segunda parte
y subimos hasta 4 y después saltamos a
esta otra parte y llegamos hasta 6
verdad entonces no está definida para
ningún valor de más chico o igual que
menos 6 por otro lado aquí estamos
viendo justamente que nuestro valor x
tiene un tope máximo verdad que es
justamente en 6 no no está definida esta
función para valores más grandes que 6
por ejemplo nuestra definida para 7 no
está definida para 8 simplemente no hay
ninguna regla que nos diga cómo operar
con x más grande que 6 verdad y por
supuesto no tenemos agujeros por ejemplo
aquí llegamos hasta menos 3 y lo estamos
incluyendo y en el siguiente paso
ya no estamos incluyendo a -3 verdad
seguimos hasta 4 no lo incluimos pero
después si lo incluimos en esta tercera
regla de correspondencia así que podemos
concluir fácilmente que el dominio
digamos vamos a expresar lo de forma muy
matemática el dominio son todos los
valores de x tales que todos los valores
de x que son números reales verdad que
es un elemento de los números reales
tales que menos 6 es más chico que x eso
es esta parte de acá arriba y es menor o
igual x es menor o igual que 6 que es
esta parte de abajo ahora bien otra
forma quizás no muy matemática de decir
exactamente lo mismo es que x puede ser
puede ser cualquier número real puede
ser cualquier número real y eso esta
parte de verdad cualquier número real
tal que tal que hay que ponerle una
restricción tal que menos 6 es más chico
que x y es menor o igual x es menor o
igual que 6 muy bien y ahí tenemos el
dominio ahí tenemos el dominio de
nuestra función ahora qué pasaría con el
rango de nuestra función y recordemos
que el rango son todos aquellos valores
posibles que puede tomar nuestra función
que verdad son todos los valores de
salida que puede tomar la función g así
que para determinar el rango tenemos que
ver cuáles son todos los valores
posibles que podemos tomar en cada uno
de estos pedazos así que vamos a ponerlo
así gx en este pedazo puede ser mayor
que algo y menor que algo aquí también
puede ser mayor que algo y menor que
algo y gtx puede ser mayor que algo o
menor que algo y por supuesto a lo mejor
en algunos casos puede incluir alguno de
los dos extremos pero eso lo iremos
viendo a medida que vayamos analizando
esta función muy bien
empecemos con esta primera parte muy
bien
si nos fijamos por ejemplo en esta
primera función que define ag x en este
pedazo es x 7 y si queremos ver por
ejemplo el valor más chico que puede
tener esta función pues correcto
corresponde justamente al valor más
chico que podría alcanzar x verdad y por
supuesto eso es cuando se aproxima tanto
como queramos a menos 6 verdad entonces
digamos que x valiera menos 6 y ya sé
que no está incluido en este intervalo
pero digamos que podemos aproximarnos
mucho mucho menos 6 en un caso digamos
extremo que valiera menos 6 la función
de aquí valdría menos seis más siete que
es una verdad es uno entonces obviamente
tenemos que el valor más chico
corresponde al valor más chico que pueda
tomar x porque estamos sumando verdad
eso corresponde a sumarle lo menor que
podamos sumar le digamos a 7 verdad
ahora bien cuál sería el valor más
grande pues cuando podamos sumarle lo
más que podamos sumar
que en este caso corresponde al valor
menos 3 verdad cuando sustituimos menos
3 en esta expresión tendremos menos 3 7
nos da 4 y ojo algo que hay que notar es
que en este caso si podemos incluir el
menos 3 verdad entonces la en este
pedazo si alcanzamos el valor 4 en este
caso no alcanzamos el valor 1 porque nos
aproximamos a menos 6 pero no tomamos
exactamente el valor de menos 6 muy bien
vamos a ver qué pasa con el siguiente
caso muy bien aquí tenemos digamos esta
función que define a este pedazo es 1 -
x quiere decir que la función está
restando x entonces para tener el mayor
valor posible tenemos que restar lo
menos que se pueda porque por ejemplo si
si restamos un número muy grande pues
esto va a quedar muy muy pequeño verdad
así que el valor más grande corresponde
a cuando restamos el valor más pequeño
de x que en este caso digamos en un caso
el límite sería
-3 muy bien entonces si sustituimos
menos 3 en esta expresión tendríamos 1 -
menos 3 sería uno más 3 que es 4 verdad
entonces el valor más grande que podemos
alcanzar es 4 y no no lo alcanzamos
exactamente verdad porque el menos 3 no
está incluido solo nos podemos aproximar
muchísimo al 4 ahora cuál sería el valor
más chico que toma esta expresión pues
justamente cuando x es el más grande
verdad porque estaríamos restando un
número muy grande un número muy grande y
eso hace que esto en en total disminuya
así que cuando tomamos el valor más
grande que es 4 tendríamos 1 menos 4
sería menos 3 menos 3 y no está incluido
verdad porque otra vez el 4 no está
incluido en este intervalo y vamos
digamos al último pedazo que tenemos 2
por x menos 11 entonces aquí nuevamente
tenemos
y que a medida que digamos x es más
grande entonces estaremos sumando mucho
quiere decir que el valor más grande que
puede adoptar esta expresión es cuando x
es igual a 6 verdad cuando x es igual a
6 tendremos 2 por 6 que son 12 menos 11
nos da 1 verdad nos da 1 pero aquí el 6
si lo estamos incluyendo así que el 1 si
lo podemos alcanzar ahora bien cuál es
el valor más pequeño que puede tomar
esta expresión pues justamente cuando x
toma el valor más pequeño que en este
caso sería 4 verdad si sustituimos con
el valor de 4 tendremos 2 por 4 que son
8 menos 11 que es menos 3 menos 3 y
nuevamente este valor si lo incluimos
porque el 4 también está incluido en el
intervalo así que con esto ya podemos
determinar el rango el rango es el
conjunto de todos los valores que de x
que son elementos de los números real
tal que qué bueno pues podemos notar que
gx puede ir desde menos 3 es el valor
más chico que puede tomar verdad menos 3
es menor o igual está incluido que quede
x y por ejemplo aquí podemos tomar
valores desde menos 3 hasta 1 pero por
ejemplo en la segunda parte podemos
tomar también valores que incluyen menos
3 hasta 1 y de hecho hasta 4 pero por
ejemplo en la primera parte podemos ir
desde 1 hasta 4 verdad y uno no lo
incluye aunque aquí si está incluido
entonces realmente tenemos todos los
valores posibles desde menos 3 hasta 4 y
por supuesto el 4 está incluido porque
aquí también lo estamos incluyendo el
conjunto de valores que quede x puede
tomar va desde menos 3 hasta 4
incluyendo los a los 2